Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du, die Ankunft der goldenen Zwanziger verspätet sich um wenige Jahre.
Grund dafür sind Faschisten im Gleis.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 506 vom 20. November 2024.
Ja, eine Sendung voller Stoßseufzer.
Das erwartet uns heute.
Wieso, war was?
Eigentlich nimmt alles nur seinen ganz normalen Verlauf.
Ganz normalen goldenen 20er. ich sag dir Tim, ich weiß nicht seitdem du das
hast, sag ich dir hör damit auf, beschrei es nicht, aber was machst du?
Immer weiter, goldene 20er, goldene 20er, goldene Schauer, goldene,
hast du nicht gesehen du siehst doch wohin das führt du meinst.
Ich hab die Dekade gejinxt.
Du bist schuld, ich wüsste nicht wer sonst,
ich schon mal nicht.
Ich hab den nicht gewählt Ja, ich auch nicht.
Also ich meine, wenn es hilft irgendwie, dann kann ich auch gerne die Schuld
auf mich nehmen, aber ich habe nicht gerade so den Eindruck,
dass das viel bringen wird.
Tja, wir hätten jetzt ja auch unser Moll-Intro einspielen können, ne?
Hast du nicht gemacht?
Ne, wir müssen ja ein bisschen Optimismus verbreiten.
So.
Fühlst du unangemessen?
Ich bin bester Dinge.
Ja.
Also wir werden jetzt ungefähr so zweieinhalb, drei Monate, wo Christian Lindner
zwar jeden Tag in der Zeitung ist, aber wenigstens nicht in der Regierung.
Das stimmt. Es war nicht alles schlecht in der Krise.
Ja, naja gut, schauen wir mal. Es tut uns ein bisschen leid,
wir haben uns eine Weile nicht gemeldet.
Es gab da eine Kaskade von Abwesenheiten und kleinen Krankheiten,
die es uns leider nicht ermöglicht hat, hier früher uns zu äußern.
Das ist jetzt die offizielle Geschichte.
Inoffizieller Grund ist natürlich,
wir wollten keine Lust uns zur Gesamt-Situation der Welt zu äußern.
Ich hatte, wie nennt man das? Ich hatte einen Rückfall.
Ja genau, nachdem wir dann sozusagen unsere Depression, unsere Kurzzeit-Depression
ausgesetzt haben, haben wir dann beschlossen, wir machen trotzdem weiter.
Hilft ja nix hilft ja nix für die Nachwelt.
Wir befinden uns gerade in dem Fork der Realität, in dem Donald Trump zum zweiten
Mal Präsident der USA wurde,
und in Deutschland also gewählt wurde erstmal gewählt wurde,
ja genau gewählt wurde, noch nicht, also das ist noch zwei Kommits weiter und dann,
die Ampel-Koalition ein faszinierendes, drei Jahre zu spätes Ende hatte,
bei dem sich erst Christian Lindner als Opfer aufführte und sich dann herausstellte,
dass eigentlich genau dieser Bruch der Koalition quasi sehr minutiös geplant
war in seinem Ablauf von der FDP.
Und Lindner nur deshalb beleidigt war, weil Olaf Scholz den Braten gerochen hat.
Also das ist quasi Olaf Scholz in den letzten drei Jahren nicht entgangen,
dass man mit dem Arsch gar nicht regieren kann.
Und er hat dann die bessere Rede gehalten und dabei eine, wie ich finde,
wie es Scholz' Art ist, diplomatisch, ruhig, quasi alles immer so ein bisschen...
Mit einer Can-Do-Attitude so ein bisschen positiv beleuchtet,
hat er dann eben gesagt, Christian Lindler ist kleinkariert,
mit dem kann man nicht regieren und ich muss das Land vor dem schützen.
Was ich, weißt du, der Mann versteht einfach auch nicht den Ernst der Situation,
selbst dann nicht, wenn er über Christian Lindler redet.
Und dann zu aller meiner Überraschung wurde dann quasi Scholz auch noch mehr oder weniger dafür,
ja, also einerseits von vielen gelobt, weil er jetzt endlich mal aus sich rausgekommen
wäre und von anderen kritisiert, weil das irgendwie streng, besonders streng
gewesen wäre, beides kann ich nicht nachvollziehen.
Ich denke, der Mann ist nach wie vor enorm beherrscht und hätte ich mit Christian
Lindner zu tun, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass es mir gelungen wäre,
eine so balancierte, ausgewogene und wertschätzende Abschiedsrede für Christian Lindner zu halten.
Also dir wären noch ein paar andere Bezeichnungen für ihn eingefallen.
Christian Lindner, ganz ehrlich. Ich meine, ich habe ja nur noch mal wieder
dieses Schulhof-Video da von dem angeschaut.
Schulhof-Video?
Ach doch, doch, natürlich kennst du das.
Wo die, da war Christian Lindner schon Christian Lindner.
Der war ja als Kind schon scheiße. Und zu Abi-Zeiten ist er dann da irgendwie
mit einem Anzug rumgerannt und mit einem gemieteten Mercedes durch die Gegend
gefahren und hat irgendwie einen auf Agentur gemacht.
Kennst du das Video nicht?
Doch, jetzt wo du es sagst, erinnere ich mich, dass ich das mal gesehen habe.
Aber ich könnte es jetzt gerade nicht.
Und da prägt er irgendwie diese Phrase, Probleme sind dornige Chancen.
Und ich meine, Christian Lindner, also kann man viel sagen, aber der Christian
Lindner ist auf jeden Fall echt eine verflucht dornige Chance. Ja.
Auf jeden Fall echt eine richtig dornige Chance.
Ja, also jetzt sind wir quasi in so einem doppelten Zwischenzustand,
sowohl über den Teich als auch hier lokal und ich glaube es gibt genug Anlass
ein bisschen beunruhigt zu sein darüber,
was so die nächsten Wahlen alles so ergeben werden.
Auf jeden Fall ist jetzt die ohnehin schon etwas magere Beschlussbilanz der
Regierung noch etwas eingeschränkt, weil jetzt kommt es irgendwie zu richtig gar nichts mehr.
Scholz setzt ein wenig da drauf, dass März, dass der jetzt irgendwie zu Sinn
kommt, da mussten sie sich natürlich dann erstmal über den Wahltermin streiten,
weil das ist ja dann auch wirklich das Wichtigste,
eine Woche mehr oder weniger.
Hauptsache, wir haben jetzt möglichst wenig Zeit, noch einen Wahlkampf vorzubereiten.
Grüße an die kleinen Parteien, die jetzt richtig den Scheiß haben,
über Weihnachten sich irgendwelche Kandidaten zusammenzufegen.
Ja, so läuft es derzeit in Deutschland.
Und keine Ahnung, also man kann jetzt, bin jetzt noch nicht so richtig bereit,
eine Bilanz dieser Regierung auszusprechen.
Aber ich denke mal im Rahmen dessen, was wir uns zumindest hier mal erhofft
haben, ist die Bilanz dünn.
Tja, also.
Katastrophale Kommunikation Sicherheitspaket jetzt zuletzt hier von Nancy Faeser
angegangen AfD stärker als je zuvor aber man kann,
also auf jeden Fall hatten die einen,
Koalitionsvertrag, an dem nicht alles weißt du, wo du nicht schon,
also weißt du, wenn irgendwie, wenn die SPD an der Macht ist, dann weißt du,
dann guckst du den Koalitionsvertrag an und sagst, ah okay,
immerhin haben die ja offenbar sich was Positives vorgenommen.
Wenn du dann eine CDU-FDP-Regierung hast oder so, dann wirst du halt weniger enttäuscht.
Ja, weil die ja auch sagen, pass auf Leute, folgendes wird sein und das dann auch machen.
Da ist die Enttäuschung geringer, als wenn dir jemand sagt, wir könnten versuchen,
hier so ein paar Sachen zu verbessern und dann denkst du, ja, man mach!
Und dann bist du enttäuscht.
Und dann kommst du irgendwann zu der Einsicht, wer hat uns verraten,
die Sozialdemokraten Und dann kommt irgendwann, wer die Sozialdemokraten verraten,
wieder die FDP. Kennen wir ja.
Das erste Mal, dass die Deutschland in eine Katastrophe kippen.
Naja.
Tja, das ist so der politische Keutus Interruptus.
Mir fällt da nicht mehr zu ein. Wir müssen halt schauen, was da jetzt so als nächstes kommt.
Auf jeden Fall ich war schon mal motivierter, was so Innenpolitik betrifft.
Also die CDU kann sich jetzt auf jeden Fall bei Christian Lindner bedanken.
Und ich meine, Man kann nur hoffen, dass die FDP ihr 1,8-Prozent-Ziel erreicht
und wir die wenigstens los sind.
Und dann werden wir sehen, ob jetzt Scholz oder Merz...
Der Scholz oder Merz, es bleibt Schmerz.
Es werden ja jetzt die Stimmen laut, die den Pistorius gerne in der Position hätten.
Der ist immerhin, glaube ich, in den meisten Politiker-Rankings einer der beliebtesten,
wenn nicht sogar der beliebteste deutsche Politiker, was du als Verteidigungsminister
echt erstmal schaffen musst.
Genau und wahrscheinlich auch der erste beliebte Minister in der Rolle eines
Verteidigungsministers innerhalb der Bundeswehr.
Oh, innerhalb der Bundeswehr auf jeden Fall.
Das ist das erste Mal, dass die Bundeswehr irgendwie das Gefühl hat,
sie wird mal so halbwegs verstanden.
Ernst genommen, ja. Wir hatten natürlich auch schon mal einen beliebten Verteidigungsminister.
Er hat dann leider sich mit seinen Disketten vertan bei der Verfassung seiner Doktorarbeit.
Die Haare schön hatte.
Herr von Guttenberg. Ja, ist schon interessant. Ich meine, eigentlich ist das
der absolute Raketenstuhl.
Also da haben sich ja echt schon so einige irgendwie den Hintern verbrannt auf
dem Posten der Verteidigung.
Aber nicht so Herr Pistorius das muss man eben anerkennen auch wenn er ja irgendwie
immer noch aussieht wie das Double von Laschet,
ob der Brüller das wäre der verwirrendste Wahlkampf ever,
wir haben beschlossen auf Wahlplakate zu verzichten bringt nichts wir.
Machen jetzt mal Inhalte auf die Plakate.
Genau,
Naja.
Es ist, also ich glaube historisch kann man nur sagen, in einer solchen,
internationalen Situation Krise und Herausforderungen,
wie die Bundesrepublik Deutschland sich gerade befindet mit dem Krieg vor der Haustür,
mit der mit der 20 Jahre zu spät kommenden Erkenntnis, dass man die scheiß Autoindustrie
so ein bisschen auf die falsche Spur geschickt hatte,
die jetzt irgendwie obwohl das jeder weiß und auch immer wusste kommt jetzt
irgendwie völlig überraschend die Erkenntnis dass E-Autos nicht nur einfacher zu bauen sind,
sondern weil sie einfacher zu bauen sind, das auch jeder kann und quasi diese gesamte.
Einbildung von Vorherrschaft oder Marke oder so, die diese deutschen Automobilhersteller
hatten, sich halt in Luft auflöst und dass die deutsche Wirtschaft da halt zu,
riesigen Anteilen dranhängt,
wovor seit Jahrzehnten gewarnt wird.
Jetzt tritt das plötzlich ein und alle sagen so, ach was, hä?
Das kann aber nicht sein, die wollen jetzt kein Diesel mehr kaufen?
Verstehe ich aber überhaupt nicht.
Und in einer solchen Zeit, in der dieses Land halt echt so richtig erkennbar auch in den Arsch geht,
Dann eine Regierung über drei Jahre aus egoistischen Motiven zu sabotieren,
ist etwas, was ich ja wirklich überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen kann.
Tja, sag's mit Christoph Schlingensief. Scheitern als Chance.
Ja, aber es wäre halt schön, wenn Scheitern als Chance mal auch die Chance für
jemand anders ist und nicht für denjenigen, der scheitert.
Ja, aber es ist halt auch, wir können darüber hin und her intellektualisieren.
Ich glaube das Wahlvolk wird das tun, was es dann immer tut.
Nachdem irgendwie ausreichend eine Regierung unter grünen Beteiligungen durchskanalisiert
wurde, danach wird halt einfach wieder CDU gewählt. Weil das haben wir ja schon immer so gemacht.
Und dass aber im Wesentlichen die ganzen Probleme, die diese Regierung auf dem
Tisch hatte, das Resultat von zwei Jahrzehnten CDU-Regierung war,
das wird halt so überhaupt nicht reflektiert.
Und deswegen drehen wir uns da einfach weiterhin im Kreis.
Ja, das ist auch wirklich faszinierend. Und die CDU-Regierung kann dann erfolgreich
sein, weil sie sich die tatsächlichen Probleme einfach nicht als lösungsrelevant definiert.
Und dann am Ende sagt er mal, was haben wir hier für ein 1A-Regierung hingelegt?
Ähnlich wie es ja dann auch Trump
regelmäßig gewissermaßen gelingt das ist schon sehr ernüchternd alles.
Ja das stimmt,
also falls ihr jetzt diesen Podcast eingeschaltet habt damit ihr wieder Hoffnung
und die Zukunft für eine gute Laune macht, wie sonst.
Bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob wir da heute so liefern können.
Wir schauen mal, was sich noch machen.
Ich hab doch gesagt, ey, wir blicken auf gute drei Monate ohne Christian Lindler in der Regierung.
Ja, okay, gut.
Also ich mein, hey.
Potenziell sogar noch mehr.
Ja, nur dann halt.
Aber ganz ehrlich, Christian Lindler ist zwar ein Problem, aber nicht unser
größtes und einziges Problem.
Dein, eine dornige Chance. Christian Lindner ist eine dornige Chance.
Anyway.
Lass uns einfach mal kurz ins Feedback reinschauen zur Erheiterung.
Lass mich raten, EPA und Rubik's Cubes. Wie viele Kommentare zu Rubik's Cubes? Einige.
Also es gab ja diesen ganzen Komplex, ich weiß gar nicht, wie sind wir da überhaupt drauf gekommen?
Also wir hatten ja hier die Sache mit dem Schachbrett, da wurde natürlich fleißig zu kommentiert.
Die Google-Strafe in Russland.
Genau, die Google-Strafe.
Hatte uns dahin geführt.
So war es, genau. Und Aros Azul stellt dann erstmal fest, hier zum Schachbrett,
da wird nicht irgendein Bauer belohnt, wie ich glaube ich sagte,
sondern Sissa Ibn Dahir, der Erfinder des Spiels Schach.
Zumindest der Sage nach, soll er für seine Erfindung dieses Spiels sich eine
Belohnung ausüben dürfen.
Daraufhin kam die Geschichte mit den 1, 2, 4, 8, 16 Reiskörnern,
beziehungsweise Getreidekörnern, je nach Überlieferung.
Er führt dann in den Kommentaren auch noch die ganze Originalgeschichte aus.
Die gebe ich jetzt mal nicht wieder, das könnt ihr dann selber nachschlagen.
Aber natürlich, wie das so ist bei uns, bei unseren Hörerinnen und Hörern,
die ja immer gerne alles sehr genau genommen.
Ich habe ja gesagt, dass da 2,64 Getreidekörner dann auf diesem Schachbrett rumliegen.
Das konnte man natürlich so nicht stehen lassen. Da gab es dann einen interessanten
Thread, wo dann Green Red erstmal einstieg und meinte, auf dem Schachbrett liegen
übrigens nicht nur 2,64 Reiskörner, sondern allein auf dem letzten Feld liegen so viele.
Also insgesamt seien es ja doppelt so viele. Woraufhin ja dann aber korrigiert
wurde, es seien nur 2,63 auf dem letzten Feld, weil er auf dem ersten Jahr eins liegt und nicht null.
2 hoch 0 und so weiter ist ja schon 1 und so.
Damit wurde also Schäppi-Schäldern fest, damit hat Tim also recht mit 2 hoch 64.
Die fehlende Minus 1 fällt ja fast nicht mehr ins Gewicht, woraufhin Max sagt, aber nur fast.
Wir müssen hier schon korrekt bleiben und anprangern, dass Tim und Linus von
einem Reiskorn zu viel ausgegangen sind.
Bitte nächste Folge korrigieren, was wir hiermit getan haben.
Ich lag also um einen Reiskorn daneben.
Fast wäre es ein Sieg gewesen für mich, aber so ist es halt nun mal.
Und dann sind wir irgendwie noch auf Rubik's Cube gekommen und dann habe ich
dann irgendwie als alter Mann erzählt, man müsste Vaseline in seinen Cube reinschmieren
und überhaupt nur das Original.
Ich habe es natürlich komplett übersehen, selbstverständlich,
weil womit beschäftigt man sich heutzutage so.
Es gibt natürlich mittlerweile eine totale Sportindustrie rund um diese ganzen
Rubik's Cubes herum und natürlich gibt es totale Spezial-High-Speed-Cubes mit
irgendwie Magneten und alles mögliche. hier.
Garn-Speed-Cubes wurden in dem
Fall erwiesen und natürlich gibt es auch so Special Loops, so spezielle,
Schmiermittel, die man da noch zur Anwendung bringen kann anstatt irgendwie
Vaseline, weil wer Vaseline nimmt und noch einen alten Original-Cube benutzt,
der lebt ja im letzten Jahrhundert und das ist ja auch so.
Kennst du die Regel 34? Ja, ne?
Ja.
Das ist jetzt ausgerechnet dafür auch ein Gleitgild gibt, scheint mir eine Anwendung davon zu sein.
Das ist ein spezielles Gleitgild.
Immer das richtige Gleitgild nehmen.
Ich komme auch meiner Auswahl für die unterschiedlichen Bereiche des Lebens,
kaum hinterher, wie viele unterschiedliche Formen von Silikonspray man braucht.
Gut. Weiteres Feedback gab es dann zum elektronischen Personalausweis.
Nee, das war die elektronische Patientenakte, über die wir gesprochen haben.
Ja, die ganzen Abkürzungen natürlich, die elektronische Personalakte.
Aber es ist auch wirklich, also ich habe mir kürzlich einen neuen N-Paar geholt.
Ja, der sogenannte Neue.
Ja, der wird umbenannt. Der elektronische Personalausweis, der hieß ja elektronischer Personalausweis.
Bis ihn alle hatten und dann wurde er umbenannt in neuer Personalausweis,
obwohl er dann nicht mehr neu war, damit man die elektronische Patientenakte
nennen konnte und nicht...
Neue Patientenakte. Oder erste Patientenakte. Aber okay, da gibt es Kommentare zu.
Ja, gibt's. Ein anonymer Schrub dir, glaube ich.
Ich habe gerade LNP505 angehört und denke, dass ich noch etwas zur EPA ergänzen kann.
Ich arbeite aktuell an den Frontends für die Krankenkassen.
Die Kassen können dann diese Module bei sich einbauen, entweder nur als SDK,
also als Software Development Kit oder gleich mit unseren User Interfaces,
natürlich mit eigenem Style und so weiter.
Daher habe ich die elektronische Patientenakte schon viel aus Patientensicht verwendet.
Zu deiner Befürchtung, dass jeder Arzt gleich sieht, dass man einen Befund als
Hypochonder hatte, kann man gleich ausräumen.
Man kann jedes einzelne Dokument verbergen, sodass man es nur selber einsehen kann.
Wenn man dann noch Angst vor einem Datenleck bei der Gematik hat,
kann man jeden einzelnen Eintrag auch komplett löschen. Allgemein bin ich selber
positiv überrascht, wie man hier wählen kann, wer genau Zugriff zu seinen Daten hat.
Man kann jede beliebige LEI, das ist Leistungserbringer Institution, komplett blockieren.
Dann erhält sie nie wieder Zugriff auf diese EPA.
Du kannst also Dr. Pritlaff blockieren und der bekommt nicht mal Zugriff,
wenn du deine Karte in sein Telematikmodul steckst.
Ebenfalls lässt sich die Zugriffdauer manuell einstellen. Man kann auch einem
Arzt, mit dem man nur telefoniert hat, vorübergehend Zugriff zu seiner Akte geben.
Es wird also kein Fax mehr benötigt.
Hinzu kommt, dass jeder Zugriff, jede Suche in der EPA etc.
Protokolliert wird. Man kann also nachträglich sehen, was von einer LEI angesehen wurde.
In meiner Meinung nach, aus Patientensicht, freue ich mich daher aktuell auf
die EPA, werde aber nie Daten darin lassen, die auf gar keinen Fall öffentlich
werden sollten, da sicher irgendwann die Gematik gehackt wird.
Zusätzlich befürchte ich, dass die Ärzte lange Zeit brauchen werden,
bis sie brauchbare Daten eintragen werden.
Ich habe einige Ärzte im Bekanntenkreis und keiner davon hat Lust dazu, noch mehr abzutippen.
Eventuell wird es ja in der von dir befürchtete Datenmüll, auch wenn ich ihn
in der App ein wenig aufbereiten kann.
Ja, da würde ich nur zu sagen, derartig feingranulare Zugriffsrechtsmanagementmöglichkeiten,
die müssen natürlich dann auch nur eine stabile technische Entsprechung haben.
Und da bin ich mal gespannt. Da bin ich mal sehr gespannt, was das Ende des Jahres noch bringt.
Ja, Zugriffsrechte tendieren immer dazu, Leuten den Zugriff zu versperren und
wenn die dann welchen haben wollen, dann wird immer schnell irgendwas daran
geändert, weil es ja sonst alles viel zu kompliziert ist.
Weitere Anmerkungen von Doc Martin zum Thema EPA.
Als jemand, der Anfang des Jahres fast gestorben und nun schwerbehindert ist,
bin ich erstmal ganz bei Tim, dass eine EPA doch eigentlich eine praktische Sache wäre.
Das ganze Jahr renne ich als Folge meiner Krankheit von einem Arzt zum anderen
und fände das richtig geil, wenn ich da meine ganzen Befunde einfach auf meinem
Kärtchen mit dabei hätte. Nun, die Realität des deutschen Gesundheitssystems
sieht leider anders aus.
Kein einziger Arzt hat sich allein meinen Entlassungsbrief aus dem Krankenhaus
komplett durchgelesen.
Da wird schnell mal die Epikrise überflogen. Das ist so quasi die ärztliche Zusammenfassung.
Und das war es auch schon. Die Reha-Befunde haben schon niemanden mehr interessiert.
Wie die digitale Speicherung von Befunden hier auf einmal mehr Lesezeit herbeizaubern
soll, ist mir schleierhaft.
Anmerkung, das wird ja so oft immer erwähnt. Wie viel Zeit haben eigentlich
die Ärzte wirklich dafür übrig, sich damit zu beschäftigen.
Weiter. Dazu kommt die oben schon angesprochene mangelhafte Granularität bei
der Gewährung von Zugriffsrechten.
Wenn ich vor jedem Arztbesuch alle Dokumente neu bewerten und auf privat öffentlich
stellen muss und der ärztlichen Person adäquaten Zugriff zu verschaffen,
dann kann ich auch die notwendigen Papierbefunde ausdrucken oder aus einem Archivordner
raussuchen und mit zum Arzt nehmen.
Summa summarum bringt mir die EPA keinen
Vorteil, nur das Risiko einer unstrukturierten zentralen Datenhalde.
Meine zwingend notwendigen Daten wie Medikamentenplan, Implantatausweis muss
ich sowieso immer bei mir tragen.
Und diese sollen ja auch im Ausland für Rettungskräfte verfügbar sein.
Daher als Papier im Geldbeutel.
Und Befunde muss ich gerade bei komplexer Krankheitshistorie sowieso immer vor
dem Arztbesuch vorbereiten und griffbereit dabei haben, damit ich die Ärztin
gezielt an bestimmte Aspekte erinnern kann. Leider heißt Digitalisierung in
Deutschland immer nur, analoge Papierberge in digitale Papierberge zu verwandeln.
Die Chance, diesen Transformationsprozess als Anlass zu nehmen,
die Datenspeicherung und Kommunikation zwischen den Beteiligten neu zu denken,
wird immer wieder grandios versemmelt.
Was würde ich mir wünschen, dass man sich mal auf ein standardisiertes Datenformat
einigt, in dem alle Labore in Deutschland beispielsweise Blutwerte zur Verführung stellen?
Und wo ich als Patient dann einfach aus meiner EPA die Daten auf meinem Rechner
mit einer bevorzugten Open Source Software darstellen kann.
Eine eher negative Betrachtung, sag ich mal.
Und Pascal wiederum fügt aber noch hinzu, danke für die Einordnung des Gutachtens zur EPA.
Zwei Punkte möchte ich noch beitragen. Vieles steht ja schon in den Kommentaren
in unserer hausärztlichen Praxis. Also hier ist mal die Praxisseite, kommt hier mal zu Wort.
In unserer hausärztlichen Praxis stellen sich viele Patientinnen und Patienten
neu, also zum ersten Mal vor.
Hier erwarte ich für mich, wie auch für Krankenhäuser und andere Stellen, den meisten Mehrwert.
Meine eigenen Patienten und Patienten kenne ich ja gut. Aus vorliegenden Briefen
oder Befunden lassen sich neue bisher bestehende Diagnosen, Operationen und
Medikamente viel einfacher erfassen als bisher mit Anamnesebögen,
die nicht immer vollständig sind.
Insbesondere in meiner Krankenhauszeit gab es oft Aufnahmen,
bei denen wir von den Medikationsplänen auf bestehende Diagnosen schließen mussten,
weil einfach keine Daten vorlagen und die Patienten aber nicht auskunftsfähig waren.
Ich erwarte da auch nicht unbedingt eine Müllhalde. Im Verlauf wird es strukturierte
Daten der EPA geben und damit dann leichter durchsucht und nutzbar sein.
Zweitens wird ein Widerspruch auch immer noch im Nachhinein möglich sein.
Man muss sich nicht jetzt dagegen entscheiden. Ebenso darf man sich immer noch
im Verlauf für die EPA entscheiden, wenn man zunächst widersprochen hat.
Wen vor allem nachvollziehbar die Forschungsnutzung stört, kann auch explizit
nur dieser widersprechen.
Ja, also gemischtes Bild.
Ich denke, wir haben auch generell viel begründete Skepsis, was sozusagen die
Nutzung und Nützlichkeit dieses ganzen Vorhabens betrifft und mit Sicherheit
sind wir noch in einer Phase, wo alles noch so ein bisschen mhm ist.
Es gab noch weitere Kommentare, die unter anderem darauf hingewiesen haben,
dass, was ich in der aktuellen Spezifikation, glaube ich, keine Bilder hochgeladen
werden können und diese DECOM-Dateien, die ich, glaube ich, erwähnt hatte,
so auch noch gar nicht vorgesehen sind.
Ja, okay. Also das läuft natürlich alles sehr langsam an, aber es gibt auch
auf der Ärzteseite durchaus Einschätzungen, dass das vielleicht auch hilfreich sein kann.
Auf jeden Fall ist das Thema hilfreich für den 38C3, der Chaos Computer Club dankt.
Wir werden uns mit dem Thema beschäftigen.
Der HALFNAB ist ja jetzt online und man kann da schon sehen,
dass es zu diesem Thema einen Vortrag geben wird von Martin Tschiersig,
der nicht zum ersten Mal sich zu dem Thema Gesundheitsdatenverletzung äußert auf dem Kongress.
Ja, HALFNAP, sollten wir vielleicht
mal kurz erwähnen, ist sowieso ein furchtbarer Name, wie ich finde.
Also das ist sozusagen, wer jetzt auf dem 38C3 sein wird oder auch nur online
daran teilnehmen möchte, hat die Möglichkeit jetzt schon einen Vorabblick zu
bekommen auf das Programm.
Unter HALFNAP, da schreibt sich H-A-L-F-N-A-R-P, frag mich nicht,
was das heißt, .events.de.
Weißt du das nicht?
Es ist irgendwie….
Ein Anagramm auf Fahrplan.
Ja, das ist super.
Weil so Anagramme sind ja auch immer so genau das, was einem so als erstes kommt.
Egal, die KI kriegt es wahrscheinlich noch auf die Kette.
Das steht auf dem Fahrplan.
Da muss der Junge in den Haftner ab schauen.
Und weißt du, das Programm, mit wem wir dann den richtigen Fahrplan machen, das ist der Fullnab.
Wovon ist das ein Anagramm? Na, na? Weiß es wieder nicht.
Es ist ein Geheimnis für die curious Listener.
Genau, das ist dann was für die Kommentare.
Da seht ihr also, wenn ihr da drauf klickt, seht ihr irgendwie alle,
zumindest alle derzeit veröffentlichten Vorträge. Ich weiß nicht, sind das wirklich alle?
Aber noch zwei, drei in der Hinterhand, die noch nicht angekündigt sind.
Genau, irgendwas mag noch fehlen und ist ganz geheim.
Auf jeden Fall kann man da draufklicken und dann werden da Daten gesammelt,
ganz gemein, sodass man besser planen kann, was man wohl in welchem Saal liegt
und vor allem auch, wenn man sieht, dass viele,
wenn zum Beispiel zwei Vorträge von denselben Leuten beide gesehen werden,
dann werden die unter Umständen nicht zeitlich nebeneinander gelegt und sowas.
Theoretisch.
Übrigens, wenn wir eh schon gerade über den Halfen abreden, da ist relativ,
also einige Sachen dürften den Hörerinnen und Hörern von Logbuch Netzpolitik bekannt vorkommen.
Fake Shops von der Stange, von Cantorkel, das wurde hier glaube ich in der Sendung
behandelt, also der Bogus Bazaar Analyse.
Da ist noch einiges zu erwarten.
Was gibt es denn noch? Was wer könnte denn noch den Leuten bekannt sein?
Oh, schau mal da. The Politics of Intellectual Shame heißt ein Vortrag.
Guck an.
Jetzt werden LNP schon zu Vorträgen beim Kongress.
Meredith will da sein.
Zwei Vorträge.
Das wusste ich aber nicht, dass sie unter dem Titel sich anmelden wird.
Vielleicht hat sie das sozusagen getan.
Das wusste ich auch nicht. Das hat sie auch erst danach getan.
Ah ja, wahrscheinlich, weil ich den Titel so gut gewählt habe.
Weil du den Titel so gut aus ihren Worten gewählt hast. Meredith wird sprechen.
Thorsten und ich machen ein bisschen was zu Wildsoftware und zu Wildsoftware
in den Niederlanden gibt es auch was.
Der Thüring-Test.
Der Thüring-Test, ja.
Das ist gut, gefällt mir. Guter Witz.
Ja, eigentlich alle Themen haben wir hier schon mal gehabt.
EPA, Cebro spricht auch nochmal über die EPA, aber dann eben auf der politischen, im Track Politics.
Ich glaube, also das Programm ist, glaube ich, ziemlich ordentlich.
Geheimplan gegen Deutschland, ein Jahr danach, Jean Peters war auch hier zu
Gast. Das ist alles, also die Verwertung der Kongress ist in zwei...
Best of LNP ist das.
Nein, ist es natürlich nicht. Es gibt sehr viel mehr Kongress-Vorträge,
als wir dieses Jahr überhaupt Sendungen hatten. Leider.
Ja, war ein bisschen voll.
Gut, soviel zum Thema 38 C3 erstmal, oder? Hast du noch irgendwas hinzuzufügen?
Nee, ich denke, das also reicht.
Ja, dann haben wir noch die andere komische Wahl gehabt.
Die meisten von euch werden es mitbekommen haben.
Es sprach sich irgendwie rum.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, hast du da irgendeine Meinung zu?
Meinung? Meinung habe ich eine mal gewohnt. Scheiße.
Donald Trump hat die Wahl zum Präsidenten in den USA gewonnen und es ist wie ein Fiebertraum.
Also er hat jetzt da irgendwie den entfernten Verwandten von John F. Kennedy, den Robert F.
Kennedy, der bekannt ist als
Ex-Junkie und Impfgegner, hat er jetzt zum Gesundheitsminister gemacht.
Und von da an ging es eigentlich nur noch bergab. Ja, also es ist ein einziges,
ein einziges, ein einziges, also es ist ein einziges Trainwreck.
Also man muss sagen, er hat die noch nicht dazu gemacht, das sind Vorschläge,
die müssen ja noch angenommen werden.
Da steht dann noch der dann künftig von den Republikanern dominierte Senat und
der von den Republikanern dominierte Kongress das Haus sozusagen auch noch entgegen,
weil die müssen ja dann irgendwie diese Vorschläge auch annehmen.
Es ist durchaus davon auszugehen, denke ich, dass der eine oder andere Vorschlag
auch abgelehnt werden wird.
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass er alle diese Leute durchbringt,
weil es halt teilweise haarsträubend ist.
Unter anderem diesen Fox News Moderator mit irgendwie Nazi-Tattoos,
der irgendwie jetzt Verteidigungsminister werden soll und so Geschichten.
Also da kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass jetzt wo sozusagen Trump ohnehin
komplett auf Durchmarsch steht.
Dann man zumindest in so einer geheimen Abstimmung, das ist nämlich dann immer
im Senat, noch der eine oder andere Muskel dann doch nochmal angezogen wird.
Aber grundsätzlich steht es da nicht gut um Amerika und insbesondere mache ich mir Sorgen,
abgesehen von den ganzen konkreten politischen Entscheidungen,
mache ich mir halt einfach Sorgen um den generellen Umbau des Staates,
der halt hier sicherlich auf der Agenda steht, um sicherzustellen,
herzustellen, dass auch in den nächsten Jahren die ganzen Trump-Kinder dann
auch noch irgendwie Präsident werden dürfen.
Das ist sicherlich gravierend.
Ich meine, was aus unserer Perspektive hier bei der netzpolitischen Brille natürlich
noch eine Rolle spielt, ist die Rolle von Elon Musk in dieser ganzen Angelegenheit.
Der reichste Mensch des Planeten,
der sich das soziale Netzwerk Twitter vor einiger Zeit gekauft hat und das irgendwie
zu einer Senke für Hass und Verschwörungstheorien hat aufblühen lassen.
Dem außerdem ein Satelliten-Internet-Netzwerk gehört,
dem eine Flotte aus hochvernetzten Kraftfahrzeugen gehört, die sich ganz gut verkaufen.
Zumindest in den USA.
Und der ein starker Dienstleister für das US-Raumfahrtprogramm ist,
mit seinen SpaceX-Raketen.
Und jetzt auch
noch eine zentrale Rolle als eigentlich Berater Donald Trumps spielen soll im
Department of Government Efficiency, DOGE.
Also Humor hat er.
Und das wird alles das sind so wirklich dystopische Entwicklungen die da sich
gerade die da gerade stattfinden also so,
Wirklich dystopisch.
Kryptobanker irgendwie als Handelsminister vorgeschlagen. Also das nimmt auch
überhaupt gar kein Ende.
Das ist wirklich fast in jedem Bereich. Aber Musk spielt natürlich eine besondere Rolle.
Ich meine, dessen mentaler Niedergang, der war also auch gut abzulesen,
aber das scheint ja heutzutage niemand mehr daran zu hindern,
solche Leute zu unterstützen.
Und ja, da wird jetzt einfach viel Revenge laufen. Viel Vorbereitung auf ewigen Machterhalt.
Und was Musk angeht, dessen Einfluss und nicht nur seinen Einfluss,
sondern halt auch der Einfluss von Peter Thiel, darüber haben wir ja auch schon
mal gesprochen, der im Wesentlichen die ganze Vizepräsidentschaft von J.D.
Vance zu verantworten hat, weil er da einfach sehr viel Geld reingesteckt hat.
Das sind halt einfach diese strangen, tech-libertären Netzwerke,
die jetzt quasi Teil dieser Machtergreifung geworden sind.
Und diesen ganzen Machtapparat, der ihnen quasi zur Verfügung steht über die
ganzen Netzwerke, Infrastrukturen.
Offensichtlich nicht zu schade sind, diese auch für ihren eigenen Vorteil zu
nutzen und das eben auch noch auf so einer politischen Ebene.
Und wenn ich höre Government Efficiency, dann klingt das für mich halt einfach
nach so einem bürokratischen Purge.
Und davon kann man durchaus ausgehen, dass also jetzt da quasi mit der dicken Sense versucht wird,
jeden, der noch irgendwie halbwegs klar bei Sinnen ist, irgendwie aus dem bürokratischen
administrativen Apparat rauszuschneiden, bis da einfach wirklich nur noch die
Vollloonies am Start sind, die das Lied von Trump singen.
Bei den Gerichten hat es ja schon ganz wunderbar funktioniert und da lässt sich
gerade wirklich relativ wenig Optimismus rausquetschen aus dieser ganzen Orange.
Die wir da präsentiert bekommen haben.
Ich war ja nicht dafür unbedingt, dass wir dieses Thema hier behandeln,
weil es mich in letzter Zeit sehr genervt hat, mir anzuhören,
wie irgendwelche Leute diesen Erdrutschsieg deuten.
Es ist nicht so, dass es ein Knapp-Rennen war oder sonst was,
sondern das war sehr schnell, sehr eindeutig.
Deutlich, ist auch nicht irgendwie Trump hätte nicht the popular vote oder so,
sondern der hat da irgendwie völlig klar,
stehen die Zahlen alle in seine Richtung, da gab es überhaupt kein Vertun,
das war auch sehr schnell erkennbar, das an den Zahlen.
Und jetzt wird natürlich viel versucht, sich zu überlegen, woran das denn liegt,
dann wird gesagt, ja, das lag aber jetzt daran, dass die Kamala Harris eine
Frau war, oder dass sie falsche Hautfarbe hat oder so, und dann gibt es natürlich auch welche, die sagen,
was weiß ich, das liegt daran, dass
sie sich irgendwie für Transrechte eingesetzt hat oder was auch immer.
Jetzt kommen sie alle und sagen, was sie schon immer gesagt haben,
nämlich, dass sie das schon immer gesagt haben und.
Betonen das. Ich denke, zumindest müssen wir wohl erkennen, irgendwie hat die
Message von Kamala Harris nicht verfangen und Und ich glaube,
es ist tatsächlich so, dass es heute eine halbwegs gesunde, progressive Position
ist, die sich den Herausforderungen des Planeten widmen möchte,
potenziell die Leute tatsächlich überfordert.
Und das beobachtet man ja nun mal nicht nur in den USA, sondern das ist etwas,
was man weltweit beobachtet.
Jetzt gibt es aber auch Stimmen, die, und wir haben auch damit diskutiert,
ob wir das in der Sendung behandeln oder nicht, wir wollen es jetzt einfach
mal behandeln als Phänomen, die sagen, da gab es Wahlmanipulation.
Und,
also es ist faszinierend, finde ich dass man sich das anschaut und sofort sagt, Spinner,
also quasi dadurch dass diese Trumpisten seit vier Jahren irgendwie einen von
der Wahlmanipulation rumgeschrien haben bis dann am Ende die Wahl so war,
wie sie die haben wollten,
ist jetzt eigentlich jeder, der irgendwo auf Wahlmanipulationsmöglichkeiten
hinweist, sofort irgendwie im Abseits.
Und da gibt es jetzt jemanden, der macht nicht zum ersten Mal und der präsentiert
da irgendwelche Dinge und wir werden die jetzt hier mal besprechen.
Aber das Spannende daran ist, kann eigentlich kaum noch jemand beurteilen. Warum?
Weil sie elektronisch gewählt haben.
Also vielleicht ließe sich hier etwas vielleicht ließe sich hier auch etwas überprüfen.
Du kannst ja gleich nochmal aufrollen, was dort behauptet wird.
Allein der Weg, um all das wirklich letztlich zu überprüfen,
endet dann auch schon beim Supreme Court.
Und wenn der sagt so, ah ne, komm mir nicht so, ja, dann ist die Sache sowieso schon vom Tisch.
Und da wir ja wissen, wie der Supreme Court gerade so aufgestellt ist in den
USA, Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass hier irgendwas nennenswertes bei rauskommt,
wahrscheinlich sowieso gering.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist es ein interessantes Gedankenexperiment,
was eben damit zusammenhängt, dass eben in den USA ein Großteil der Stimmen,
insbesondere ein Großteil der Stimmen in diesen sieben entscheidenden Swing
States mittlerweile halt elektronisch tabuliert wird mit dem Wahlsystem von I&S und Dominion.
Und ja, da gab es ja schon bei der letzten Wahl viel Aufregung da drum mit irgendwelchen
Trampleuten, die dann einfach mal einmarschiert sind, die Kisten beschlagnahmt
haben, wo dann irgendwie Kopien gezogen wurden etc.
Bevor er da eingeschritten wurde. Also nichts Genaues weiß man natürlich nicht.
Der Vorwurf, der jetzt hier von Stephen Spoonamore, so ein Cyber Security Experte
kann man ihn vielleicht nennen,
auf jeden Fall arbeitet er schon längere Zeit in diesem Bereich und war in dieser
ganzen Debatte auch schon seit längerer Zeit anwesend.
Und der hat halt gesagt, okay, er hat schon immer davor gewarnt,
wie wir das ja auch getan haben vor Wahlcomputern,
der sich auch die letzten Wahlen angeschaut hat und meinte, da wäre jetzt sagen
wir mal so noch nichts wirklich aufgefallen.
Aber diesmal sei ihm etwas aufgefallen.
Teil dieser Tabulation der Stimmen in den USA ist auch wohl eine statistische
Auswertung des Stimmverhaltens, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Das heißt, es werden Zahlen veröffentlicht, zum Beispiel darüber.
Wie Wahlzettel ausgefüllt wurden.
Und zwar ist es nicht, wer hat da was gewählt, das natürlich nicht,
weil es soll ja den Wahlstimmen nicht ansehbar sein, wer abgestimmt hat, aber das wie natürlich.
Und eine Besonderheit sind sogenannte Bullet Ballots.
Bullet Ballot ist sozusagen ein Stimmzettel, also es ist ja jetzt Zettel,
auch wenn es da elektronisch gewählt wurde, also teilweise wird auch mit Papier
gewählt, ist ein bisschen verwirrend.
Auf jeden Fall, Bullet Ballot ist einer, wo quasi nur für die Präsidentschaftswahl abgestimmt wurde,
obwohl in den allermeisten Städten oder in allen ja auch noch die Kongresswahl,
also die Abstimmung zum Haus, teilweise eben auch Senatswahl und gegebenenfalls
auch noch weitere lokale Abstimmungen, die dann parallel noch mit durchgeführt wurden,
auch noch zur Verfügung gestanden hätten.
Aber es gibt wohl einen auffälligen hohen Anteil dieser Bullet Ballots ausgerechnet
in Swing States und da auch nicht überall, sondern nur in einigen Wahlkreisen.
Und was heißt auffallend? Also normalerweise liegt es wohl so im unter 1% Bereich
und hier in den Swing States war es wohl teilweise 5, 6, 7%.
Also schon deutlich höher als das eben normalerweise ist.
Also so eine Auffälligkeit, die einem erstmal so zu denken geben kann,
was denn da jetzt irgendwie passiert ist und seine These ist jetzt die,
dass hier gegebenenfalls mit den Wahlcomputern Stimmen gefälscht wurden und
jetzt wird es ein bisschen abenteuerlich.
Also es ist ja auch noch so, dass es so ein Registrierungssystem gibt und es
gibt wohl eine Software, die
heißt ePoll Books und diese Software wird in den ganzen USA eingesetzt,
um quasi abzulegen,
wer denn jetzt hier gewählt hat
und noch wählen darf, also wer sozusagen überhaupt registriert ist etc.
Sprich die Software, die die Leute benutzen, um rauszufinden, ob jemand wählen darf.
Sprich man taucht da irgendwie auf und dann steht quasi in dieser Software drin,
wer jetzt gewählt hat, damit eben diese Leute nicht doppelt wählen.
Ich vermute mal, es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, dass man irgendwie an mehr als
einem Ort wählen kann, USA teilweise in manchen Stellen, das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau.
Auf jeden Fall ist diese Software auch vernetzt.
Naja, weiter geht die Geschichte, dass es ja nun diesen Fall gab, wo Elon Musk diese,
ja so eine Art Lotterie ausgerufen hat im Vorfeld der Wahl um irgendeine,
ich weiß gar nicht, worum ging es denn da eigentlich bei dieser Petition?
Du musst dir so irgendeinen relativ unklaren Pledge unterschreiben und da wurde.
Jeden Tag eine Million verlost.
Und dieser Pledge, da stand jetzt nicht drin, ich wähle Donald Trump,
aber da stand ihm so, ich werde alles tun, um Amerika vor dem Bösen zu schützen, so sinngemäß.
Er ist dann übrigens auch drangekommen, er hat eine Untersuchung in der Strafanzeige
bekommen, eben wegen unreguliertem Glücksspiel, weil du kannst nicht einfach eine Lotterie machen.
Das ist also, weil wenn jemand sagt, ich mache hier mal eine Lotterie,
begründeter Anlass für die Annahme besteht, dass das vielleicht bei der Lotterie
gar nicht ganz so sauber zugeht.
Deswegen wird so etwas gemeinhin kontrolliert oder reguliert.
Hat er auch in irgendeinem Staat dann deswegen Ärger bekommen,
aber letztendlich hat er halt einfach
jeden Tag gesagt, wenn du das Ding unterschreibst, verlose ich eine Mio.
Da haben natürlich viele unterschrieben und da vermeintlich ihre Daten dann eben angegeben.
Genau, zumindest die Daten, die man jetzt bräuchte, um quasi auch als Wähler
überprüfbar zu sein, sprich Name und Adresse.
Naja und die These ist jetzt die, dass irgendwie diese E-Poll-Books-App quasi
abgeschnorchelt wurde oder es da irgendeinen Realtime-Zugang gab oder irgendeinen anderen Hack,
der quasi Leute in Echtzeit während der Wahl in die Lage versetzt festzustellen,
wer denn sozusagen nicht gewählt hat.
Und dann auf einem zweiten Wege dazu zu sorgen, dass dann eben solche Bullet-Ballots
abgegeben werden, wo dann halt einfach nur Trump gewählt wird.
Also das Problem ist das was der hier schreibt er sagt zum Beispiel hier in
Arizona sind es irgendwie,
123.000 solcher Stimmen, die nur Donald Trump wählen, aber sonst sich nicht an der Wahl beteiligen,
also in Arizona 7,2% in Nevada 5,5 und dann nimmt er angrenzende Staaten Idaho,
Oregon, Utah müsste das sein,
wo die gleiche Art quasi ein absolutes Nischenphänomen von 0,03,
0,05 und 0,01 Prozent ist.
Und genau in den an den Staaten, Arizona und Nevada, das sind dann eben Swing
States, an denen genau diese Menge, dieser Anteil dann auch entscheidend ist.
In Arizona ist es eben genug, um das Ergebnis zu drehen und in Nevada ist es
genug, um die Schwelle für einen Recount zu überschreiten.
Also wenn das zu wenig ist, wenn der Unterschied zu wenig ist,
könnte man halt nochmal einen Recount machen.
Ich weiß noch nicht, also ich weiß noch nicht mal, ob diese Zahlen hier stimmen,
weil scheint da jetzt auch nicht, also es gibt jetzt nicht unabhängige Dritte,
die sagen, genau, wir haben die Zahl geprüft, der steht. Vielleicht hat er alles
mit Chat-GPT geschrieben.
Aber es ist, also dass er jetzt eine derartige Theorie entfalten kann und dass sie gleichzeitig,
offenbar noch nicht so wirklich mal verfängt und geprüft wird,
nachdem halt die ganze Zeit nur von Wahlfälschung geschrieben wurde, Vielen Dank.
Zeigt halt, wo wir sind mit diesem Thema, ne?
Ja, nichts ist beweisbar, alles ist irgendwie, alle sind demotiviert,
hier überhaupt noch irgendwas zu tun.
Situation in den USA ist halt jetzt besonders im Eimer.
Da freue ich mich jetzt sehr, dass unsere damalige Aktivität in Deutschland
vom Club und anderen Beteiligten letzten Endes beim Bundesverfassungsgericht
zu dem Ergebnis geführt hat,
dass diese ganzen elektronischen Methoden von der Wahl möglichst fernzuhalten sind.
Das heißt, wir haben dieses Problem so nicht,
beziehungsweise dieses Szenario hier wäre so überhaupt nicht vorstellbar in
Deutschland, das kann so nicht stattfinden und das finde ich schon mal sehr
beruhigend, aber wir sehen ja,
Wahlbeeinflussung findet auch auf viele andere Arten und Weisen statt,
also die Leute wählen dann trotzdem irgendwie ihren Untergang,
egal wie die Software ist.
Also da ist nicht vergessen, der Swoon and More sagt halt, also es gibt ein
relativ einfaches Verfahren, das zählt halt neu aus, zeigt mir die Zettel,
zeigt mir, dass das alles stimmt.
Und dazu müsste sich aber Kamala Harris sozusagen offiziell beschweren.
Dafür hat sie in manchen Staaten nur noch bis Freitag Zeit und er meinte auch,
er wüsste noch nicht mal, ob sie seinen Brief gelesen hat.
Also er hat so ein Duty-to-Warn-Letter rausgebracht, wo er sozusagen sagt,
ja hier, mir ist was aufgefallen, bitte reagiere, bitte melde dich und ob das
stattfinden wird, werden wir sehen, weil das natürlich dann so auch gleich wieder
Teil des politischen Diskurses wird. so.
Du willst natürlich auch, ich kann auch wirklich verstehen, dass dieser Pfad,
Zweifel an der Wahl zu äußern, der ist halt auch wirklich so ein bisschen sowas
von Trump kaputt getrampelt worden.
Auf den Pfad willst du dich doch nun wirklich nicht begeben.
Ja gut, ich meine, was haben sie jetzt noch zu verlieren, ne?
Also was hat ausgerechnet Kamala Harris jetzt noch zu verlieren?
Eigentlich gar nichts. Ich meine, er hat ja im Prinzip alles verloren.
Ich weiß aber trotzdem nicht, ob sie es tun werden. Und wie schon gesagt,
wenn man sich halt jetzt den rechtlichen Weg anschaut, den das nimmt,
kann das Ganze dann im Supreme Court scheitern und da wird es auf jeden Fall
scheitern, weil der Supreme Court gehört halt mittlerweile auch Trump.
Ja, dennoch wäre es im Zweifelsfall jetzt schon wünschenswert,
dass wenn ein Mensch derartige Beobachtung schildert,
dass ihm entweder jetzt gesagt wird, ey Junge, du hast die Auswertung falsch gelesen,
das stimmt nicht, was du sagst.
Oder dass man dann sagt, okay, pass auf, ich werde das jetzt,
als Dienst an der Demokratie diese Neuauszählung oder die Prüfung veranlassen,
damit Sicherheit besteht.
Also das wäre ja vielleicht der sinnvolle Weg für Kamala Harris,
das zu tun und zu sagen, hier, da gibt es Zweifel und damit die jetzt ausgeräumt werden, strenge ich,
an, dass da jetzt bitte die Zweifel ausgeräumt werden.
Wir sind richtig im Flow, oder?
Ja, macht halt Spaß.
Das einfach, es geht runter wie Öl. Wie Schweröl.
Noch so eine schöne Entscheidung gab es in, wo war das? Köln? Nee.
Ja, welches Gericht, das war in Jülich, beim Amtsgericht in Jülich.
Ja und zwar erinnern wir uns an den Fall Modern Solution, eine Software,
die irgendwie so zur Verwaltung von Online-Shops verwendet wurde und da gab es einen Kunden,
der diese Software verwendet hat und der hatte irgendwelche Probleme und hat
einen Programmierer gebeten, kannst du mal bitte das Problem lösen, was ich hier habe.
Der Programmierer hat sich diese Software angeschaut, das war eine EXE-Datei,
MS Connect, Modern Solution Connect und die hat er sich angeschaut und festgestellt,
dass diese Software eine Verbindung zu einer SQL-Datenbank bei Modern Solution herstellt.
Ja, also das war also eine Exe-Datei, eine ausführbare Windows-Datei,
die mit einer Datenbank spricht,
die gehostet ist bei einem Server von dieser Firma Modern Solution in Gladbeck.
Und diese Software war dazu gedacht, dass du jetzt als Kunde deine Online-Shop-Lagerbestände,
Warenwirtschaft oder in irgendeiner Form deine Online-Shop-Prozesse oder Verkaufsprozesse
dort in dieser Datenbank bei Modern Solution verwaltest.
Und in einem solchen Falle wäre es absolut das Minimum.
Dass jeder Kunde dieser Software seine eigene Datenbank hat.
Dass also der Kunde A eine eigene Datenbank hat mit eigenen Zugangsdaten,
der Kunde B eine hat, der Kunde C eine hat.
In diesem Fall war es aber so, dass diese Software MS Connect sich mit einem
Nutzernamen und einem Passwort verbunden hat, der für alle Kunden des Unternehmens
wiederum der gleiche war.
Das heißt, dieser Programmierer, der sich einmal manuell ohne die Software der
mit dieser Datenbank verbunden hat, hatte Zugriff auf 70.000 Daten von Kundinnen und Kunden.
Von allen Kundinnen und Kunden. Von Modern Solution.
Und hat er gesagt, Modern Solution hier übrigens müsst ihr anders machen.
Und die haben gesagt, du bist ein pöser Hacker.
Weil du hast, jetzt kommt das, was man ihm vorgeworfen hat, du hast ja in dieser,
ausführbaren Echse geschaut, wie die Zugangsdaten zu unserer Datenbank sind.
Und die haben wir ja extra nicht irgendwo übermittelt mit einem Brief oder mit
einer Brieftaube oder mit einem Zelt oder mit einer Konfigurationsdatei,
wie es richtig gewesen wäre übrigens.
Sondern wir haben die ja in der Daten, in dem Programm versteckt.
Und das Programm war ja eine Exe-Datei.
Und du hast die ja jetzt mit einem Texteditor geöffnet, diese Exe-Datei,
und dann darin das Passwort gesehen.
Bei Unix-Systemen oder bei mir sehr beliebt ist das Programm oder der Befehl
Strings, den du auf Binary,
Objekte üblicherweise ausführst, zum Beispiel auf so eine ms-connect.exe,
die alles, was in ASCII ist oder als ASCII interpretierbar ist, ausgibt.
Was bei dieser Art von Fehler oder ähnlichen Arten von Fehlern eben auch Textteile
in ein Programm einfach auswirft.
Und die Argumentation von Modern Solution war lächerlich, technisch inadäquat
und komplett dumm, weil der Fehler eindeutig bei Modern Solution war.
Und vom Amtsgericht Jülich sind die mit dem Quatsch durchgekommen.
Und das war im Januar, das haben wir hier, denke ich, auch ausführlich berichtet,
und jetzt ging dann der Fall in Berufung nach Aachen und in Aachen haben sie
die Scheiße nochmal geglaubt und haben gesagt, ja klar, du hast ja hier,
eine wirksame Methode, das Passwort zu verstecken,
um Gang und deswegen bist du zu Recht bestraft worden und das ist so unglaublich dumm.
Das ist so, also ich kann jetzt gar nicht erklären, wie doof das ist,
also wie unglaublich falsch das ist,
zumal dieser Programmierer ja noch dazu, oder dieser Verurteilte,
das noch dazu ja gemacht hat,
im Rahmen einer Tätigkeit bei der Problembehandlung bei einer,
weil bei denen die Datenbank zugemüllt war.
Das heißt, er hat noch dazu ein Problem von Modern Solution gelöst,
was Modern Solution seinem zahlenden Kunden verursacht hatte.
Und ich kann gar nicht, also es ist eine absolut katastrophale Entscheidung
des Landgerichts Aachen,
die immerhin zeigt, wie bescheuert unsere sogenannten Hackerparagrafen sind.
Aber das ist also mir fällt gar nicht,
also mir fällt überhaupt nicht ein also.
Also ja, im Zweifelsfall hat das Gericht hier das Gesetz einfach mal richtig
interpretiert und deswegen sind wir auch die ganze Zeit gegen das Gesetz an dieser Stelle,
aber es ist in seiner Wirksamkeit absolut katastrophal, Dass da in der Firma
eine komplett eindeutig idiotische Software,
die nicht nach aktuellen Standards fahrlässig gebaut und verteilt wurde und
dann geht jemand und meldet das.
Ja, meldet es ja sogar. Er hat sich ja in keiner Form irgendwie so verhalten,
dass irgendjemand einen Schaden gehabt hätte, sondern hat das dieser Firma gemeldet
und wird jetzt am Ende dafür kriminalisiert,
obwohl das, was er getan hat, letztendlich ein gemeinnütziger Akt war,
wie Fabian Scherschel auch bei Heise schreibt.
Das ist wirklich zum Heulen.
Zum Heulen und in der Berichterstattung im Januar hatte sich ja wohl schon so berichtet,
dass die jülichere Richter sich dahingehend geäußert hätten nach Sichtung der
Rechtslage, das ja wohl offensichtlich mit dieser Verschärfung des Paragrafs 202a 2007,
der offensichtliche Zweck dieser Änderung sei ja das Hacken als solches unter Strafe zu stellen.
Was natürlich erstmal, wenn man jetzt rein begrifflich da mal rangeht,
schon mal fragt, okay, was ist denn dann Hacken?
Also es ist dann sozusagen diese negative Bewertung des Vorgangs,
aber eben in dem Moment, wo man das eben als Sicherheitsforscher macht,
ist ja, kann man auch sagen, ist ja auch Hacken, aber halt zum anderen Zweck.
Also egal wie es gemeint ist, ist es sozusagen böse. Und der Gesetzgeber hat
ja immer behauptet, nee, nee, das ist ja nur ein Schlimmeres zu verhindern.
Und die Novelle, jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, ist sie jetzt eigentlich beschlossen
worden oder ist sie jetzt mit unserer Regierung untergegangen?
Die Änderung des Paragrafen.
Ich glaube, also kann sein, dass sie es noch zu Ende führen,
aber beschlossen wurde sie nach meiner Kenntnis bisher noch nicht.
Ja, genau so. Könnte also passieren, dass es jetzt sozusagen noch unter die Räder kommt.
Ja, das würde mich nicht wundern. Danke Christian Lindner.
Ja, also ein vollkommenes Missverständnis dieser Problematik,
die letzten Endes unsere Systeme und damit auch unsere allgemeine Infrastruktur
nicht sicherer macht, sondern genau das Gegenteil.
Weil es können halt solche Spotzelboden wie Modern Solution,
die mal ganz offensichtlich von ihrem Werk, von ihrem Handwerk nichts verstehen,
weil wer so argumentiert, dokumentiert einfach nur,
dass einfach die nicht verstanden haben, wie Software zu funktionieren hat,
wie Sicherungssysteme funktionieren haben und so etwas würde ja keiner Überprüfung
standhalten, wenn man jetzt mal von außen kommt und sagt, und bewertet so,
ja, guck mal, unsere Software hier haben wir geschrieben,
kannst du mal drauf gucken, sag mal, wie gut das ist.
Und dann kommt halt der Experte und sagt, ist das euer Ernst oder was?
Wollt ihr vielleicht mal was mit Holz machen?
Also ich arbeite ja im Bereich der IT-Sicherheit.
Dann hört ihr davon.
Und sagen wir mal, dass irgendwelche Juristinnen und Juristen,
die von dem Sachverhalt keine Ahnung haben,
Diesen Prozess, eine Sicherheitsuntersuchung zu machen, in den wenigsten Fällen,
in irgendeiner Weise, sagen wir mal, beschleunigen, enablen oder verbessern,
gehört zu den traurigen Erkenntnissen. Ja.
Dass eben du nicht per Dekret sagen kannst, das ist jetzt, also das machen wir
jetzt sicher, dadurch, dass wir verbieten, die Sicherheitslücke zu suchen.
Das ist genauso wie wir verhindern jetzt Attentate, dadurch,
dass wir das Mitführen von Messern verbieten.
Also es ist, so denken Juristinnen und Juristen über solche Sachverhalte nach
und solange man so über solche Sachverhalte nachdenkt, wird sich eben nichts
an der tatsächlichen Sicherheit ändern,
weil derjenige, der mit einem Messer Straftaten begehen will,
wird nicht sagen, oh das mache ich lieber nicht, weil ich darf ja kein Messer mitführen.
Und genauso ist es so, wenn du sagst, die Straftat, die wir verhindern wollen,
ist, dass jemand solche Daten ausliest und im Darknet verkauft oder zum Schaden anderer verwendet.
Wenn wir das verhindern wollen, dann dürfen wir nicht das Finden der Schwachstelle kriminalisieren.
Weil irgendjemand muss es ja dann noch machen, der oder die kein Interesse hat,
sich dadurch straffällig zu werden.
Und wenn du diese Menschen alle unter einem, ja letztendlich nicht abschätzbaren
rechtlichen Risiko agieren lässt,
ja, dann sind eben nur noch kriminelle Hacker unterwegs und niemand meldet mehr Schwachstellen.
An dieser Stelle sei auch nochmal darauf verwiesen, wie viele Menschen.
Ich kann es dir gar nicht sagen, da müsste man mal schauen, wie viele Schwachstellenmeldungen
wir als TCC inzwischen machen, jede Woche,
weil Leute, die welche gefunden haben, sich nicht trauen, die zu melden.
Nochmal, ich finde es halt, also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du auf so Vollidioten
stößt, die so etwas dann zur Anzeige bringen, ist nach wie vor enorm gering, ja,
aber wenn du dann auch noch das Pech hast, in zwei Instanzen vor Gerichten zu
landen, die auch nicht den fucking Sinn ihrer eigenen Gesetze verstehen,
ja, dann brauchst du dir auch keine Gedanken mehr zu machen,
ob aus diesem Land nochmal was wird.
Dann machen wir das auch nicht.
Okay, machen wir nicht. Dann kommen wir zum nächsten Thema. Der BND hat sich
überlegt, ja pass auf, weil er mit den Cyber-Gefahren hier kein Ende hat.
Ist ja auch so geil. Man darf ja eigentlich gar nicht hacken.
Haben wir ja jetzt gesehen.
Ja, ist verboten.
Ist verboten. Und dann sagt er, jetzt müssen wir aber, weil das irgendwie kein
Ende hat, müssen wir jetzt zur Abwehr von Cyber-Gefahren, die Kommunikation
zwischen Menschen im In- und Ausland überwachen.
Also wenn jetzt Leute in Deutschland mit Leuten im Ausland kommunizieren.
Eine Argumentation, die du jetzt quasi gar nicht so einfach machen kannst,
weil ich weiß nicht, ich will nicht wissen, wie viel Kommunikation zwischen
zwei Deutschen einfach über Server in den USA geht, aber das ist von außen vor.
Sagen sie, also wir wollen jetzt hier so eine Überwachung und da greifen wir
dann Datenströme ab und die werden wir dann nach Suchbegriffen filtern und eventuell
sogar händisch sichten.
Und damit greifen wir natürlich in die Grundrechte nach Artikel 10 ein und hier
dieses Fernmeldegeheimnis und das dürfen wir auch solange ein Bundesgesetz das regelt.
Und diese Regelung wurde jetzt mal in Karlsruhe geprüft und da gab es dann einiges
dran auszusetzen mit den Rechten, die dem BND da eingeräumt werden sollten,
nämlich erstens gibt es keine hinreichende Regelung zur Aussenderung von Daten
aus rein inländischen Telekommunikationsverkehren.
Also das Beispiel, was ich gerade meinte, Linus schreibt über Gmail eine E-Mail an Tim,
dann ist das ein rein inländischer Telekommunikationsverkehr,
der über ausländische Server stattfindet, deswegen aber nicht notwendigerweise
vom BND abgehört werden darf, weil es ja hier zwei deutsche Grundrechtsträger sind,
die nicht quasi im Einzugsbereich des BND sind, solange wir uns beide in Deutschland aufhalten.
Zweitens, auch wenn ich jetzt ins Ausland gehe oder eine ausländische Person,
das ist, geht diese Überwachung zu weit, denn der Kernbereich privater Lebensgestaltung
ist nicht ausreichend geschützt.
Und drittens, wenn dann ein solcher Eingriff in meine Grundrechte stattgefunden
hat oder TIMS oder einer ausländischen Person,
dann wird das nicht ausreichend lang dokumentiert.
Also die Aufbewahrungsfrist für die Dokumentation, dass man das getan hat,
ist zu kurz, sodass nämlich dann das unabhängige Kontrollorgan,
die sogenannte G10-Kommission,
keine ausreichend gestaltete Kontrolle darüber hat.
Und ja, also auch völlig klar, dass man so etwas, also dass es derartige Einschränkungen
geben muss, aber auch das hier wieder nur auf irgendeiner juristischen Ebene.
Die müssen jetzt glaube ich bis 2026 das nachschärfen, dann schreiben sie da
irgendwie rein, ja das muss so und so kontrolliert werden oder darf nur so und
so lang sein oder hier, da müssen
wir aufpassen, dass wir inländische Grundrechtsträger nicht miterfassen.
Dass das am Ende sich technisch sowieso nicht realisieren lässt wird dann noch
auf einem anderen Blatt stehen und das werden die Richterinnen und Richter dann
wieder nicht mehr prüfen oder nicht mehr nachvollziehen oder.
Ob das was im Gesetz steht von der Realität sich überhaupt decken lässt spielt
ja in zunehmendem Maße eine untergeordnete Rolle.
Es ist eh alles egal.
Ach,
also juristische Regelungen im Bereich der IT und spezifisch der IT-Sicherheit
kann ich, also sowohl wenn sie jetzt, sag ich mal,
das Strafrecht, wie jetzt hier im Bereich der Hacker-Paragraphen betreffen,
als auch wenn sie irgendwie so, was weiß ich, was du an Quatsch unterschreiben
musst, um einen Pentest irgendwo zu machen.
Das zeugt einfach davon, dass da Menschen,
also das halt, ich bin wirklich inzwischen bei der Überzeugung angelangt,
dass halt, weißt du, solche Regeln sind immer der Versuch, gesunden Menschenverstand zu formalisieren.
Und ich glaube, wir müssen irgendwann mal uns der Erkenntnis hingeben,
dass wenn du versuchst, gesunden Menschen Verstand zu formalisieren,
du am Ende in einem Konvolut aus regulatorischem Unsinn mündest. Ja.
Mein Beispiel wäre die deutsche Steuergesetzgebung. Das hat schon alles irgendwie
seinen Sinn und jeder einzelne Satz, der da drin steht,
dient dem Zweck, irgendein Schlupfloch oder irgendeine Ungleichheit oder Ungerechtigkeit
auszumerzen und schafft dadurch eine neue.
Und es wäre, ich sehe das im Bereich dieser IT,
Sicherheitsrechte oder sonstigen in ähnlicher Form.
Ja.
Und Überwachungsgesetzgebung ebenfalls, wo dann irgendwie gesagt wird,
hier haben wir jetzt irgendeinen Safeguard oder so und das ist alles nur irgendeine
Papierscheiße, da hat überhaupt nichts mit der Realität zu tun.
Und am Ende wäre das einzig Sinnvolle zu sagen, nein, wirft ihr nicht fertig. Ja.
Genauso wie der Modern Solutions, der böse, böse Modern Solutions Hacker,
der aufgezeigt hat, dass das Unternehmen,
seine Kunden und deren Kundinnen in vollkommen fahrlässiger und inkompetenter
Weise verwaltet hat und dafür, die gehen straffrei aus.
Und derjenige gesagt hat, guck mal hier, das scheint mir nicht sinnvoll,
der kriegt dann noch eine Strafe dafür.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch für unser Rechtssystem.
Bleiben Sie messen.
Gut, dass wir da die Richterinnen und Anwältinnen mit beschäftigt haben. Herzlichen Dank.
Danke für euren Beitrag. Wir fragen euch nächstes Mal gerne wieder.
Weiß man, was man aber auch nicht darf bei diesen Überland-Kommunikationen, Auslandsverkehren.
Was man nicht darf?
Ja genau, darf man nicht. Also was man nicht sollte.
Was man nicht sollte. Kabel durchschneiden ist ganz böse. Aber so in der Ostsee,
also als Kabel und als Leitung lebt es sich in der Ostsee gerade nicht richtig gut. Warum?
Also die Ostsee wird zur Offline-See langweilig.
Ja, und zwar ist da jetzt ein Tiefseekabel zwischen Deutschland und Finnland kaputt.
Konkret zwischen Helsinki und Rostock?
Ja, also Finland und Deutschland in dem Fall. Und da gingen die Daten durch
und jetzt irgendwie gibt es da keinen Ping.
Und dann mehren sich die, mehren sich die Verwunderung über ein chinesisches
Frachtschiff, was da in der Nähe war und sein AIS irgendwann mal ausgeschaltet hat.
Kennung, wo es sozusagen sich gerade befindet. Ah, das hat es getan, ja, das Schiff.
Ja, da gibt es jetzt, also das sind jetzt so erste Untersuchungen,
aber es wäre jetzt, also kurz zuvor ist ein Kabel zwischen Schweden und Litauen kaputt gegangen.
Und da war auch schon ein...
Ist entweder ein Kapitän echt lange unter Anker gefahren, ohne das zu merken?
Oder das ist ein enorm großer Zufall?
Oder jemand machte Kabel kaputt, absichtlich.
Also in dem anderen Fall war es auch tatsächlich ein Anker.
Also meiner Kenntnis nach war das an der Stelle tatsächlich ein geschleppter Anker.
Inwiefern das Absicht war, das steht jetzt sozusagen nochmal auf dem anderen Blatt.
Aber ich habe den Fall auch nicht so verfolgt. Auf jeden Fall ist das Datenkabel
CLion1, also C-Lion1, ist kaputt.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wo das jetzt war. Hast du die Stelle auch irgendwo
notiert gesehen? Irgendwo in der Ausseite?
Nee, also die genaue Stelle nicht.
Ja,
und ist kaputt. Und jetzt weiß man erstmal nicht ganz genau,
war es jetzt irgendwie das China-Schiff oder war es irgendwas anderes.
Ich glaube, man kann sagen, diese Kabel gehen nicht von alleine kaputt.
Und das ist natürlich sehr beunruhigend, was quasi so mit der Infrastruktur passiert.
Allerdings hat es in Finnland keine dramatischen Auswirkungen gehabt,
denn Finnland hat auch noch andere Verbindungen und ja, Femmsly ist das Internet
ja mal so designt worden, dass es auch den Atomkrieg überleben kann.
Stimmt natürlich nicht, aber egal, alte Legende.
Und dementsprechend ist das natürlich nicht das einzige Kabel.
Es gibt aber so Länder, bei denen könnte das durchaus so sein,
dass das dann auch mal das einzige Kabel ist.
Also wenn da so ein Kabel ausfällt, dann sieht es schon mal nicht so gut aus.
Aber da gehört Finnland natürlich nicht dazu, weil die wissen ja,
mit Telekommunikation und so weiter kommen die ganz gut klar,
haben Verbindungen nach Schweden, nach Estland und darüber dann eben auch noch
über andere Hops mit dem Rest der Welt.
Von daher passt das schon, aber es ist natürlich nicht so schön und es ist vor
allem sehr beunruhigend zu sehen, was so mit unserer im öffentlichen Meer ausliegenden
Infrastruktur derzeit so alles passiert.
Okay, kommen wir zu den guten Nachrichten.
Ach echt, wir haben gute Nachrichten?
Wir haben gute Nachrichten?
Was?
Eine lustige Nachricht.
Ja, wir haben noch gute Nachrichten für euch. Wenn ihr jetzt schon zusammengebrochen seid.
Möchtest du den Jingle abspielen, um die Leute wieder aufzuwachen?
Ach, das ist jetzt sozusagen schon ausreichend. Okay, schauen wir mal.
Und zwar haben wir hier regelmäßig im Logbuch Netzpolitik auch über den Alex
Jones gesprochen, den Betreiber der Webseite infowars.com.
Eine, ja was war das, also auch irgendwie so ein, also eigentlich ein Shop für
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel.
Betrieben von einem völlig durchgeknallten Verschwörungstheoretiker, der dort irgendwie,
ja wildesten wildesten Irrsinn seit Jahren verbreitet und enorm große Zuhörerschaft in den USA erreicht.
Aber nicht nur irgendeiner, sondern eigentlich schon so einer der populärsten
und so ein bisschen auch das Sinnbild für diesen ganzen Wahnsinn der letzten zehn Jahre.
Der hat auf jeden Fall als erstes an den Frosch gelegt. Und die,
eine der schwerwiegendsten, also der war eine Zeit lang einfach relativ lustig,
hat sich ja auch über die Homosexualität bei Fröschen längere Zeit aufgeregt und so.
Und dann der war eigentlich immer relativ, war alles ganz beschaulich,
bis er dann irgendwann anfing,
nach einem Massaker in den USA, so ein,
Schulshooting und zwar das von Sandy Hook die Verschwörungstheorien die Welt
zu setzen, diese Kinder seien da alle gar nicht gestorben und dann irgendwie die Menschen,
die dann da den Verlust und die ihrer Kinder oder die Traumatisierung ihrer Kinder und das Schwere.
Schicksal will ich jetzt nicht,
aber diesen schweren Schicksalsschlag der Community verarbeitet haben,
die hat er halt alle als Statisten und Lügner bezeichnet und die haben dann gegen ihn geklagt,
weil sie natürlich infolgedessen schweren Anfeindungen aus dem Internet ausgesetzt
waren und haben Recht bekommen.
Und er wurde irgendwie dann nach alter Gründerväter-Sitte in den USA zu irgendwie,
was weiß ich, anderthalb Milliarden Schmerzensgeld an die verklagt und fertig ist.
Und damit ist er dann in die Insolvenz gewandert und so kam dann eben sein ganzes
Infowars.com-Imperium unter den Hammer.
Und dann konnte man darauf bieten und gewonnen hat The Onion und The Onion ist
ja eine bekannte traditionelle,
Parodie, Satire Seite der USA so kann man das glaube ich ganz sinnvoll beschreiben.
Oder?
Ja, so das Vorbild.
Für den Postillon auf jeden Fall.
Und The Onion hatte interessanterweise nicht das höchste Gebot mit ungefähr
drei oder dreieinhalb Millionen US-Dollar für den ganzen Schnatterer-Deng.
Aber sie hatten von einigen der Sandy Hook-Opfer quasi.
So Erklärungen, dass sie auf ihre Schadensersatzansprüche oder große Teile davon
an Infowars.com verzichten, wenn The Onion.
Das erfolgreiche Gebot ist. Das heißt, die Onion hatte nicht den höchsten Kapitaleinsatz,
aber die höchste am Ende und die höchste Schuldentilgung, was ich eine sehr
elegante Variante finde,
überhaupt mit dieser Situation umzugehen.
Und wer auch immer die Sandy Hook Opfer sind, die in einer derartigen Situation
noch, ja sagen wir mal, den Humor aufgebracht haben oder die,
vielleicht auch sagen wir einfach so, diese blutrünstige Bösartigkeit gegenüber Alex Jones, Hut ab.
Und sieht auf jeden Fall so aus und die Onion hat dann jetzt auch einen schönen
Artikel geschrieben, warum wir das gekauft haben.
Die wollen da jetzt halt irgendeine Parodie Verschwörungstheorien-Webseite betreiben
und die ganzen Nahrungsergänzungsmittel wollen sie zu einem riesigen Riegel,
einschmelzen und einen Menschen essen lassen, der dann super Kräfte bekommt.
Und das ist irgendwie das kann man auf jeden Fall ganz gute,
haben da auf jeden Fall, sag ich mal, einen ganz belastbaren Plan.
Es ist allerdings so, dass offenbar jetzt aktuell Twitter da nochmal quasi eine
Motion eingereicht hat und sagt, dass diese Versteigerung da irgendwie,
das passt ihnen alles nicht so ganz, da erheben sie einen Einspruch.
Und es ist zum Zeitpunkt, zu dem wir aufzeichnen, noch nicht ganz klar, wieso.
Die Vermutung ist, dass eben Teil dieser Insolvenzmasse auch der Twitter-Account
von Alex Jones ist oder der Infowars-Twitter-Account.
Und es kann sein, dass die Twitter-rechte Abteilung einfach nur sicherstellen will,
dass dieser Account, wenn überhaupt dann Twitter gehört und sie den ja quasi
nach ihren AGB dem Infowars da mal irgendwann gegeben haben,
dass es aber grundsätzlich in ihrer Entscheidung liegt, wem sie einen Account geben und wem nicht.
Und dass sie quasi die Präzedenz verhindern wollen, dass jetzt irgendwie Twitter-Accounts
Insolvenzmasse werden, weil dann haben sie auch einen gewissen Wert.
Und wenn sie einen gewissen Wert haben, dann haben sie den vor allem bei Twitter und nicht.
Also das war so das, was ich da bisher zu lesen konnte. Ja.
Der Alex Jones macht daraus, ja, hier, die Kavallerie kommt und Elon Musk rettet
mich jetzt und der Präsident ist involviert und Infowars wird jetzt gerettet und ehrlich gesagt,
wahrscheinlich hat er recht.
Es wäre zu schön, wenn,
Wenn dieser Mann irgendwie seine gerechte Strafe und Demütigung bekommen würde
und wahrscheinlich beschäftigen sich Elon Musk, der reichste Mensch der Welt
und Donald Trump, der baldige Präsident der USA, gerade genau damit.
Weil womit sollten sie sich sonst beschäftigen,
als der Webseite von einem verschwörungstheoretischen Hetzer,
der nichts Besseres zu tun hat, als irgendwie Trollhorden auf Menschen zu hetzen,
die schwerwiegende Verluste zu beklagen haben.
Wenn man sich fragt, warum diese Sandy Hook Opferverbände ausgerechnet The Onion
so positiv gegenüberstehen, ich meine man muss ja nicht unbedingt jeden Humor teilen,
aber The Onion ist ja für einiges bekannt.
Aber wenn vor allem für einen Artikel, den sie vor zehn Jahren schon mal veröffentlicht
haben und seitdem jedes Mal,
wenn so ein School-Shooting stattfindet, immer wieder neu veröffentlichen mit
dem Titel No way to prevent this says only nation where this regularly happens.
Der also mittlerweile schon zu einem Memen für sich selbst geworden ist,
so nach dem Motto ja, was soll man schon dagegen tun aber das ist sozusagen
nur in den USA findet das so statt aber es gibt halt definitiv keine Möglichkeit
da irgendwas gegen zu tun,
und ich glaube das dürfte einen Beitrag geleistet haben zu dem Standing,
was da The Onion in diesem Fall hat Jo.
Du hast auch eine gute Nachricht. Ja genau, wir haben auch noch ein paar andere,
lustige Sachen. Wir wollen euch ja ein bisschen aufheitern auch.
Ich habe es kurz bevor wir mit der Sendung angefangen haben,
angesprochen, da wurde mir wieder klar so, ah ja, wow, das ist ja schon wieder
alles so lange her, das weiß vielleicht gar nicht jeder.
Deswegen hole ich vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz aus, aber nur ganz kurz. Salman Rushdie ist ein.
Schriftsteller, Der schreibt Bücher. Ich habe keins davon gelesen,
um ehrlich zu sein, aber das gilt auch für viele andere Schriftsteller,
also von daher no offense.
Und der ist sowohl indisch als auch britischer Staatsbürger indischer Herkunft
und ist weltberühmend und hat viele Preise für seine Werke auch aufgenommen.
Und er hat 1988 ein Buch veröffentlicht mit dem Namen Die satanischen Verse.
Und ausgründig, jetzt nicht nachvollziehen kann,
hat eins der damals noch lebende iranische Religionsführer Ayatollah Khomeini
dieses Buch irgendwie so zum,
ja, dem größten Feind, dem der Islam hier gegenüberstand, gemacht.
Und hat Salman Rushdie gegenüber eine sogenannte Fatwa ausgesprochen,
was so viel bedeutet, wie dass Salman Rushdie jetzt hier irgendwie ein Feind
des Islam ist und man solle sich doch mal seine Habhaft machen und damit war er dann sozusagen, ja.
Mit einem Kopfgeld versehen.
Sozusagen, also eine extrem gefährdete Person, die dann zur Folge hatte,
dass Salman Rushdie von der britischen Regierung quasi aus der Öffentlichkeit genommen wurde.
Also er hat dann irgendwie mehrere Jahre quasi in so einem Versteck gelebt und
war sozusagen komplett aus der Öffentlichkeit heraus.
Das hat er dann irgendwann aber wieder sein lassen später und ist so langsam
wieder aufgetaucht, nachdem auch Krumini dann gestorben war.
Ist aber dann tatsächlich auch später durchaus nochmal Opfer eines Attentats
geworden, Weil er irgendwie bei irgendeiner Buchvorstellung dann von einem islamischen,
aufgeregten Menschen mit einem Messer angegriffen wurde, dabei sein rechtes
Auge oder sein linkes Auge, rechtes Auge verloren hat.
Also auch fast gestorben wäre. Ja, und warum erwähne ich das jetzt?
Also dieses Buch ist dann halt tatsächlich auch in manchen Ländern noch verboten, so auch in Indien.
Und jetzt gab es den Fall, dass ein Inder, Sandi Pan Khan aus Delhi,
von Simon Rashti irgendwie und auch von diesem Buch dann so erfahren hat und
ich dachte so, ah, das klingt ja interessant irgendwie, das will ich jetzt mal lesen.
Und dann sein Buchhändler, aber meinte so, ja nö, gibt es nicht, weil es ist verboten.
Dann wollte er wissen, warum, warum ist denn das verboten, wenn hier so ein
berühmter Schriftsteller irgendwie so ein Buch schreibt, warum ist das jetzt
hier verboten, warum kann ich das nicht kaufen,
und hat dann eine Informationsanfrage an das zuständige indische Ministerium
gestellt, was irgendwie sich gar nicht so zuständig fühlte und das dann irgendwie
an andere Ministerien weitergereicht hat und alle haben irgendwie versucht,
ihm sozusagen diese Informationsanfrage zu beantworten, die nämlich quasi diesen
Originalbeschluss dann hätte hervorproduzieren müssen.
Mit der schönen Nummer 405-12-88-CUS-Römisch 3.
Kurze Geschichte zu Ende.
Ja, man hat den nicht gefunden. Also es wurde sozusagen, kein Ministerium war
in der Lage, den Originalbeschluss wieder zu produzieren von Ende der 80er Jahre,
woraufhin das Buch jetzt nicht mehr verboten ist in Indien.
Schönes Ding, wie man einfach mit Informationsanfragen Ich würde gerne sehen. Ja, zeig doch mal.
Zeig doch mal dein Blatt.
Und ja, das hat auf jeden Fall funktioniert.
Und eine weitere lustige Sache, muss man auch noch erwähnen, war in Dublin.
Also am 31. Oktober, ist jetzt schon ein bisschen her, ich weiß,
aber nicht so richtig dazu gekommen, dazu berichten, war ja Halloween.
Und Halloween ist ja mittlerweile so ein globales Partyphänomen geworden,
wie so Weihnachten und Ostern und sowas, wo irgendwie alle auf einmal unglaublich feierwütig sind.
Und naja, mittlerweile ist es wohl so, bei solchen Großereignissen,
die so globalen Charakter haben,
haben dann Unternehmen festgestellt, dass dann sehr viele Leute ins Internet
gehen und dann nach entsprechenden Veranstaltungen suchen.
Also die tippen dann so ein, hier Halloween-Party, wo geht denn hier irgendwie
was bei mir und immer wenn Leute im Internet gerne Dinge tun, was passiert dann?
Dann gibt es irgendjemanden, der darauf eine SEO-Seite optimiert.
Genau, dann gibt es irgendjemanden, der sagt, oh Leute wollen irgendwie was
im Internet wissen, da produziere ich doch mal was dazu.
Und so hat dann ein Unternehmen in Pakistan darauf reagiert und hat eine entsprechende
Halloween-Event-Ankündigungsseite im Internet produziert und dann halt mit irgendwelchem
SEO-Kram dafür gesorgt,
dass eben solche Suchanfragen möglichst dann zu ihnen kommen,
was dann wohl zu einem großen Suchaufkommen führt und dann werden ganz viele
Anzeigen eingeblendet und so verdienen sie dann halt irgendwie ihr Geld.
Das ist ja irgendwie weit verbreitet.
Das Problem ist nur, dass sie natürlich dann auf dieser Webseite auch versprechen,
Veranstaltungen anzukündigen.
Also sie versuchen dann zusammen zu recherchieren, wo denn wirklich Halloween-Partys sind.
Und da heutzutage diese ganze Arbeit im Internet und diese ganze Recherche so
schwierig ist und zu viel Zeit kostet,
nimmt man da heutzutage dann Chat-GPT
und versucht sozusagen auf die entsprechenden Ergebnisse zu kommen.
Und so hatten die das dann auch gemacht, was dann dazu führte,
dass unter anderem eine Halloween Street Parade angekündigt wurde in Dublin.
Problem nur, dass es diese Veranstaltung gar nicht gab, sondern dass sich das
sozusagen die AI einfach so ausgedacht hat, weil wenn man die irgendwie falsch fragt,
dann kommt die halt wie so ein kleines Kind und da kriegt man dann immer irgendwie
eine Antwort, auch wenn da irgendwie gar nichts ist und ja, das hat Und dann zur Folge,
dass dann auf einmal am 31.
Oktober tausende Besucher in Dublin auf der Straße standen und darauf warteten,
dass diese Parade anfängt. Aber es gab halt keine Parade.
Was ist überhaupt los mit dieser Welt?
Ja, aber wieso, da gab es doch dann eine, wenn da irgendwie ein paar tausend Leute stehen.
Ja, die waren aber alle eher enttäuscht. Die wollten alle ihr Geld zurück,
was sie nicht ausgegeben haben.
Wollten alle die Gelegenheit, ihr Geld auszugeben wiederhaben.
Ich weiß es auch nicht, aber alles ist daran absurd.
Also ich scheitere schon so ein bisschen daran, dass ich irgendwie einfach nur
so im Internet irgendwo was eingebe.
Der Effekt war ja so, es ist ja nicht nur so, dass die Leute dann auf diese
Webseite gegangen sind und alle haben dann von dieser Webseite erfahren und
dann sind sie dann einfach auf die Straße gewandert und haben sich gewundert,
wo die Parade ist. Nein, nein, nein, nein, so läuft das natürlich nicht.
Ein paar Leute haben sich dann diese Information dort geholt und dann wurde
das halt weitergetragen in den Netzen,
so oh es gibt eine Parade und dann ging das halt irgendwie über alle möglichen
Kanäle und irgendwelche YouTube-Influencer haben das dann aufgegriffen und Instagram
und ja und hier die Street Parade zu Halloween in Dublin,
das wird sicherlich richtig geil und dann erfahren das natürlich dann in kurzer Zeit irgendwie alle,
niemand hinterfragt diese Informationen,
niemand sucht nach einer offiziellen Webseite, die das in irgendeiner Form bestätigt,
sondern es wird halt einfach nur so weitergetragen und dann stehen halt da alle
irgendwie auf der Straße.
Also wenn ihr euch noch wundert, warum überhaupt diese Welt Kopfsteht mit dem
Internet, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das überhaupt so eine gute Idee war.
Das sind einfach alle bekloppt, oder? Es ist einfach, es ist schlimm.
Leute, wir wollten mit dem Internet, wir hatten da wirklich.
Einen optimistischen Ansatz. Das gebe ich ja zu. Ich war auch sehr davon überzeugt
und das hat auch, glaube ich, diese ganze Hacker-Szene jahrelang getragen.
Wir dachten immer so, wenn wir euch Informationen geben und die Möglichkeit,
offen zu kommunizieren und über Sachen zu diskutieren und Informationen auszutauschen,
dann kann das ja nur dazu führen, dass sich alle lieb haben und wir endlich
mal unsere Probleme gelöst bekommen.
Und mittlerweile muss ich sagen,
nee, funktioniert so nicht. Kommt irgendwie anders gerade alles. Das ist schlimm.
Immerhin, ey, ich mein, also weißt du, da war jetzt eine Halloween Parade,
die es irgendwie in den New York Times, in den Times of India,
auf Wired.com, auf BBC gebracht hat, also,
du warst dabei, also ich meine,
und da war noch nicht mal eine, das ist doch richtig gruselig.
Das ist schlimm.
Ich bin da nicht hingegangen, ich wusste, dass das ein Fake ist.
Ich wollte erst nach Dublin fliegen.
Na toll, ich stand da die ganze Zeit rum und dachte, was ist hier los?
Was kann Dublin eigentlich? Nüscht los hier zu Halloween.
Okay, wir nähern uns dem Ende der Sendung.
Und es wird leider sich jetzt wieder potenziell eine kleine Zeit einstellen,
wo zumindest ich nicht mit bei den Sendungen dabei bin.
Ich hoffe aber, dass Tim mit Thomas oder anderen häufigen,
Vertreterinnen und Gästinnen und Leuten, die seit langem hier im Team sind,
euch die eine oder andere Sendung noch vor dem Kongress kredenzen wird.
An Themen wird es ja nicht mangeln.
Ja, mal gucken, was noch so ist.
Vielleicht haben sich ja auch ab nächste Woche alle wieder lieb und wollen nur
noch das Beste für die Welt.
Stimmt.
Könnte auch passieren, oder?
Trump wird jetzt Altersmilde.
Kriegt jetzt mal die richtigen Drogen auf den Tisch irgendwie.
Ja, dann müsste echt mal einer richtig einstellen.
Ja. Gut, Leute, dann machen wir es kurz und wir hören uns dann die Tage wieder, auf jeden Fall.
Und bis dahin, sagen wir mal Tschüss und bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.